ich bin da ich bin da ich bin da ambra
ich bin da ich bin stabil
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück bei minecraft
hero mit denen und ich laufe jetzt in
statt gelb ach ich die gar kein ton
obwohl ich den so laut habe ich ihren
star eingerichtet und dann - ich glaub
jetzt erst mal ein bisschen in die
richtung das ding ist mein stab ist
gleich kaputt ich musste ich mir so ein
mehr suchen sich dann auf dem meer
irgendwie vielleicht ein bisschen
schneller sein kann oder ist auf ein
bisschen schneller
ich muss irgendwas wird nur meine
wirbelwind boot zu reparieren
bei welchen koordinaten bist du und ich
habe darunter nicole ich bin bei 62 700
ja wir wissen jetzt die koordinaten
lasst einfach beide dahin geistert ja
wir wollen vom msc fällig land wächst so
und 5 grad jetzt muss man - 5100 muss
ich in die andere richtung - von 1000
oder 5000 - 5100 steht auch ein chat du
blödmann ein bisschen falsch gelaufen
naja ich hin und etwa jedoch in etwa bis
in den punkt da richtig gemacht so ein
bisschen die richtung sonst könnte es
werden jetzt die perfekte zeit für ein
schönes thema werden könnte angefangen
und wir uns nicht zu ende gebracht aber
jetzt können wir machen auf unseren
langen beschwerlichen weg innenstadt
statt gelb und zwar 2013 das jahres
praktisch vorbei
drommel 2013 gemacht so ein paar sachen
vorgestellt haben so was machen wir
jetzt noch mündlich 2013 ja wie finger
ist ein anhang 2013
der shop macht schon glaubt nein ich
glaube dich oder ich glaub schon
blockieren die erste serie offenbar
irgendwann fertig doch mit sicherheit
weil simon war auch der letzte gast im 7
hat es 2013 soll ich hier angefangen was
zu machen und sieht man noch der letzte
gast in etwa so ähnlich war das nicht so
kommen weihnachten rum
das war noch später weihnachten so
beschaulich unser ende wären niemals so
heißt es war nicht so beschaulich ich
dafür dass jemand mal gestorben oder so
oder so einfach nur ein riesen meteorit
und hier kommen
ach dass dieses eisblock ist hier dieser
komische eisblock ich hier was schon ein
eisblock ich bin schon bei 3001
meteoriten aber ich freue mich dass es
ihn aufzubauen
da ich glaub das wird dass jemand zu
gast
dann gab's natur beim nie was anderes
aber es war auch so was in der art der
cnt glaube ja wir haben megastar ich
geübt schon fehlt es hier für den ju
später reichende tnt noch benutzt und
zwar nicht geschieht system thesen
aircraft assistenten luke hab ich auch
er hat alles kommt auf mich zu
grundsätzlich hatten alle pferde pferde
fleisch
doch doch und da das war die guten alten
zeiten haben ja 70 folgen oder sogar
haft auf jeden fall viel ja 70 70 so
viele fahrgäste immer so dabei und
weniger witzig das kann auch hier im
zweiten tag oder abwechselnd hochgeladen
nehmen beide sicht noch geladen ist kann
mir den zweiten tag
und das war dann schon ziemlich langsam
halbes jahr oder sogar 140 tages umfasst
leute selber stimmt wir haben anfang
aber jeden tag glaube ich von da her
aber es war nicht so ganz kurz auf jeden
fall auf jeden fall ihr langes projekt
das war fällig und witzig
diese show war und dann war halt
megaprojekt ja megaprojekt war dass wir
durch so eine szene so richtig bekannt
geworden ist quasi szene
ich komme ich jetzt dahin wo ich hin
möchte
mir ist das so komisch life rohstoffe
im mai sogar zwei sogar voll beide oder
wanderschuhe auf 22
doch meine schuhe richtig schön kaputt
da war doch mal eine hektik heute dass
sie so schnell kaputt gehen
aber wir machen sie aber wir hingehen
wollen so es geht noch besser
koordinierten bist du jetzt schon bei
also bei ex habe ich halte richtig also
habe ich als 300 gleich und auch bei -
4500 4500 ist so weit vor mir ja nicht
so kaputt gemacht mainz traf noch
funktioniert wie blöd aber ich bin dann
gleich da und dann kann ich dass jemand
nicht verwandten begriffen kannst du
schon mal vorbereiten so eine kleine
öffnung chérie heute so ein haus gebaut
so wir wohnen jetzt aber ich glaube
allerdings geht auch gleich kaputt -
5100 euro sind noch 400 blöcke den ich
bin stolz auf dich bin ich da mainz oder
fackeln du bist ganz nah am ziel konnte
nicht mehr war und du kannst du uns so
sailer nun ich bin da ich bin da ich bin
da am brach ich bin da ich bin stabil
der monolog in straden gelb im oktober
farben mit oktober fahren steht der chef
von craft das dorf anrufs war füchse
zombie drin
öffne mal ist nichts drin sind an das
haus nicht wie ein zombie java aber ich
glaube denen dann stehe und so getötet
hätte ich am liebsten gekriegt stock
schon jetzt gar nicht ernst aber direkt
nemexia gelandet hab ich alles dunkel
hier die mit ein paar fackelten
hinsetzen bei denen es aber schon schon
gut organisiert hier die stadt ja aber
trotzdem verlieren sie mal ging statt
rot es ist ein staat dort sind die bar
oz was ist das für ein gras gress obwohl
ich ihn statt rot bin komisch jetzt bin
ich ihn statt gelb und das haus da
hinten finde ich schön
dem stimmt dass talkshow ein riesenhaus
dass die frist zuletzt gar kein haus
doch das ist nach hause wohnten hier ist
eine monster falle hier
ich weiß nicht wo er ist doch zum kotzen
dass ich kein staat mehr rhein-main
schwer das kaputt könnte ich nicht
einfach hier im portal machen und dann
zurück in die stadt mir was holen wieder
zurückkommen hier ist echt eine monster
veraltet
ich habe mir das wort was kannst du ja
dann wenn ein spiel das könntest du dir
dann portal waren ja dann mache ich das
doch einfach mal ich bin jetzt bei der
monster verleitet das ist gerade ein
bisschen erfahrungen sammeln das lassen
die anlage nutzen
ehrlich ich bin die amecker nachteil
dadurch ja was sind deren sachen keine
ahnung ich weiß nicht wie es mir regeln
festgelegt ist es war nur eine frage ja
aber die haben dadurch kein nachteil die
neue wo ich hätte gar fast mein spiegel
zerstört
ja ich mache jetzt eben auch gar kein
spiegel wirtschaftlichkeit ein doch ich
habe ein spiegel mit
da muss ich angehen ich muss jetzt ehren
der ein spiegel muss ich hier haben hier
so hin
denn hier so nah und deaktiviert zack
zack zack
ok und jetzt kommt wird der rucksack
geöffnet der spielt kommt rein
und das ist der stadt spiegel und der
muss jetzt lange drücken
richtig gehört wieder ging ins gesicht
geschlagen hast noch tun
oh mein gott alter das einfach zerstört
ich kann in eure stadt geht und dann in
meine stadt speyer das ganze machen dass
es zerstört trotzdem hab und gut um ein
baumhaus das ist das von der chip so
jetzt habe ich mir aus wie allen städten
hat gelb ich kann ja mein spiegel geben
dann geht es zur stadt geld und dann
machst du dann engagiert der für alle ja
ja doch tut er fast jeder macht das
beten
ja ich mache erst mal mit dem spiegel
hier für mich aber nur für eine sexy
kahle sind okay okay gut dass ein fairer
deal
sie haben auch ein friedensvertrag wir
sind ja verbindet
das einzige was wir hassen stadt pink
die sie gerne zu euch ich aber nicht
dass wir die spiele ganz kaputt macht
lena mache ich nicht ich benutze nur
unter deiner oppach tisch da plaudert
rot-rot ort wie der tod
ich finde wieder das was unsere mini ich
finde das nie schwer waren zu dumm für
whistler scheißhaus von dem ich bin in
statt rot ja ich bin noch nicht wieder
als ich hab's gefunden
ja und ich möchte am liebsten einfach
nicht mehr existieren
ich habe einfach machten heute hier um
aufgenommen acht folgen dann hast du
über die feiertage musste nicht alles
wegen das ganze wird dann bei denen über
den spiegel nicht benutzen wenn du
irgendwie dem gebäude steht wenn du hier
drunter stehst ich weiß ich muss aber
erst in meinem haus gehen wir jetzt auch
in meinem haus machen um ihren einzug
stationen weltkriege demnach aber schon
wird über 100 ration operation
kooperation beginnt
das hallo hab mein ahnung was locker
kommt ehrlich gesagt
ich hab sie gegeben ja ich weiß so vor
du hast mir gegeben hast dein spiegel
ja ich schon einmal hier wertvolle
sachen fusion wehe du benutzt ihn dann
wenn du du machst du mit irgendwas
falsch
nein ok wenn der traum mir ich mache nie
irgendwas verfassen
benutze den spiegel einfach ja schon
lange keinen bock mehr bei mir bist
jetzt man halt den gedrückten ein
bisschen statt geld ich muss mir erst
hier ein machen
natürlich stehen erst jetzt den rucksack
werfen richtig oaxaca stadt gap der hier
der ob du hast du dem rucksack alter du
machst dir immer wenn ich glaube ich hab
gar den staat laut den kaputt gemacht so
blöd 66 ins navi passiert von
vermeintlich ich habe 60 die kahle
finden ich bin so stolz auf mich das
heißt daraus kann ich mir erstmal wieder
an helfern machen den helm muss ich mir
machen und ich werde noch mal für die
fifa
ich bin so froh wenn die fifa die fifa
so hat mein hab ich jetzt zurückgesetzt
jetzt tue ich mein herr ein zwar dass
meine stadt jetzt ruhig mehr statt ich
meine ich das in meinem blog als vom
ersten bis zum 16 doch hier kann ich ihn
raus weine geht vom ersten bis zum 16
jetzt bereite ich komme nicht mit besser
alter den trainer
nein du bist du doof für diese welt
durch bis zu doof für die so wild ich
hasse mich war und tue ich das jetzt so
wie ich den ausgleich noch irgendeiner
hab ich gleich noch meinen eigenen das
mach ich noch nicht war zuerst muss ich
noch flugs stelle mitnehmen
vielleicht kann nichts retten unser ziel
jeder raum machst du das reisen war
alles umsonst jetzt nein vielleicht kann
ich zurück dahin
es ist alles umsonst gewesen was wir
gemacht hatte es zählt das erlebnis
ich bin nämlich in der nähe von stadtrat
herrscht allerdings hast du die
koordinaten dachte ich gleich gab es
nämlich look sterbe 300 und - 5100 noch
mal 300 und und 2500 das ist denn 53
oder die pizza bäcker 3000 bist du
durchgehend mit mit dem stab geflogen ja
ok auf denen so blöd ja ich weiß mich
hast dich ich hatte den falschen mero
irgendwie ins pacmag getan
ich hab doch ich bin nicht dafür gemacht
so was zu machen
aber immerhin hab ich noch meinen bergab
wenn das mein backup was für backup ein
backup starb beim ein backup portal wo
ich jetzt in der nähe davon wenn doch
dann darf ich jetzt aber noch eine
existenz von leben
okay aber nur eine man ist das so oder
du halt ja das war wirklich dürfen
eigentlich könnte man statt grün noch
einen film dann unten
das ist eine wasserstadt oder kommen
heute in bonn das regal
das wäre cool eine stadt der dumm wenn
wir bei der 1
ja
brost holding einen ausblick schon so
ein bisschen wow so haftet er deine ex
kfn unterwäsche den kleister oder nicht
einfach ein diamant direkt nur kannst du
dir man ein hey du hast gesagt du hast
gesagt ein diamant ja aber ich hab's zu
diamant ja gesagt haben so hexel diamant
den brauche ich noch zwei hektisch mit
dem ins alter ja aber ich möchte meine
tief richtung machen das gut leute
entlässt ihn bekommen hätte ich da ein
portal komplett zerstört aber ich kann
es jetzt neu machen so ich gehe mal
wieder zurück in meine stadt weil ich
bin nicht so doof ich bin gleich da
stadlau
wie hast du dich kaputt gekriegt was das
sogar in dem haus gehen genutzt oder ja
ich war kurz draußen weiß was passiert
ist
wie soll ich das wissen der meteorit ist
runtergefallen direkt meine füße ja und
da sind das sind auch so sachen raus
gespannter hier dieser dings typen schon
mal passiert das nicht direkt
da denkt man sich fürwahr kein teil
nicht hätte geben können
300 sagt dass du ne ich bin schon als
5000 im chat ich sehe schon die zu
fahren macht das macht das portal am
besten sofort brunnen oder so wie du
willst nicht machen wir lieber so wissen
ausblicks auf höherer ebene
ich mache das auf seinem ich mache das
aus einem auf so einem schönen hohen
berg auf dem höchsten auf dem möglichen
weg wolle
du kannst nicht genug kam haben wir
irgendwie wolle oder so wir weiß ich
nicht wann ein scheiß berg raum
ich bin zu tun das fehlt mir gerade
sonst könnte ich mir jetzt iv machen
so jetzt bin ich hier und hier wie mache
ich jetzt diesen diesen diesen scheiß
dar
also ich habe jetzt ein hab ich hier den
tue ich jetzt den rucksack der ist auf
jeden fall mal sommer safe und da ich
noch zwei andere an stoppt sind wie
komme ich zurück in meine stadt zwei
wurde ruhig
alter nehme wie bitte junge wenn du
jetzt keinen ich denke bestimmt fest
jetzt der ja du müsstest zurückfliegen
wenn du kein spiegel dabei hast ein
magic mirror den haag jetzt aktiviert so
hier leute aktivität so und jetzt
öffentlich wieder den rucksack so die
beiden sind es auf jeden fall statt gelb
und dieser hier weiß ich nicht der muss
jetzt mich retten um hause bringen was
mich am arsch wir müssen ja immer diese
blöden so muss ich nun konzept
vorstellen
damit alles gut ich glaube es gibt
keinen typischen wir in minecraft haben
sie aus gepatcht richtigen rezepte damit
gibt es noch jetzt bin ich hier unter
was drunter
so und jetzt hole ich den hier raus aus
dem rucksack und packt den hierhin und
benutzten marco durch lande zu hause ja
wohl so hier wieder einpacken dass es
also meine stadt der stadt gelb und ein
gps segert sex geben bitte so viel du
hast ich habe keine ich hab nie welche
gefahren wenn er nicht durch zufall
bekommen ich gucke nach und ich sehe
keine aber you can have you like i am
sailing geoportal kontra bayer kommt zu
mir weil ich glaub ich hab jetzt vor
hunger gleich also wenn ich dir gekommen
ich kann aber nicht so schnell die wolke
aber du hast ein portal amir kabbani
holen ich habe keinen stich bekommen
hatte ich komm installiert
schönberg das tor und kommen in main
statt
ich komme nicht hoch zu dir weil ich
denke nein ich habe an der treppe wo ist
die treppe hier um mein gott alter dass
er richtige adresse geheimgang dürfen
also willst deine haben ja okay kann ich
dir helfen
doch da
dann mache ich das eben meinen staat
geld noch mal drauf dann kriegst du den
wieder das casting war doch bestimmt
aber du hast ihn verlassen selbst
gemacht ja auf einen beobachter passt
wie ein makel an das ist geil da stimmt
natürlich
man hat den erstdruck aber er denkt
manchmal das ist gut fürs image
das muss mir merkel halte hoch so der
spiegel ist jetzt darauf fokussiert
jetzt kann ich den spiegel wieder da
reinpacken
die müssen wir jetzt kurz dort suchen wo
ich mich unter einem blog stelle so hier
machst nicht kaputt jetzt müssen wir
nachdenken das ist auf jeden fall deiner
da gehe ich nicht mehr daran muss die
stadt roth nehmen
ich hatte durch nachdenken nachdenkt ist
nicht gut ich bin bei dir kommt zu mir
komm mal runter eben schnell das geht
schneller weil wir haben wir überziehen
schon wieder runter ok ich schaue mich
erst einmal gar nicht mehr aus dem haus
raus weil ich immer denke ich hab
spiegel in der hand da wartet er der
postbote 11 kaputt nein es nicht kapiert
wir sind doch unter einem blog nein
wieso bist du denn herr bedeuteten doch
gar nicht in der hand nicht optimal da
passt schon
du willst ja erst mal nicht zum statt
gelb landsleute auch ich habe ja noch
ich habe selbst auch einen statt geld ja
extra zwei gemacht gut wenn du weißt
dass du irgendwann zu dürfen wie es ja
ja gut freunde ich gehe zurück in meine
stadt
wir haben den finde ich viel geschafft
na ja geht es mir auch hier ein spaß bei
uns geht es nicht voran kommen um später
werdet auch spaß schreibt uns doch mal
rein die kommentare hier spaß hatte und
erst nach oben
wenn jetzt für den tipp und dann erwarte
ich mit heutigen folge shop.com crafter
von beiden china beschreibung und
macht's gut
ich möchte ganz gedanken hat in der
nächsten folge machen uns bei der
nächsten folge werde ich mir die tief
aber fertig machen die welt dann heftig
verzaubern damit ihr war bogner ist
natürlich nicht vielleicht auch einfach
mal jetzt